[Music]
so will smith in the building actor
let's see rapper rapper TV show yes
philanthropist Antipas we go later a
cook yeah I just I just threw that in
I'm not even sure that's true
welcome to the show I appreciate you
spending the time so I want to start
talking tech for a little bit so so you
came up in the era of classics of hip
hop of all these things and I just got
to go way back to the beginning what's
your favorite piece of retro tech from
back in the day so so jazzy jeff was the
biggest tech head in all of Philly so
he's crazy so it was the first time that
MIDI of even though yes so I don't even
know people even know what MIDI a
multiple medical instrument digital
interface right yeah so it was the first
time that you could take two drum
machines and string them together right
so Jeff had the 909 and the 808 and it
was the first time that you could sync
music together from two separate
machines that sounds like some real
Flintstones stuff yeah so the first time
that Jeff made a beat that could sink
keyboards and multiple machines and make
it play at one time was the most amazing
thing that's like bleeding-edge
yeah that was bleeding edge technology
that you could make a piece of music and
hit one button and make the whole song
play from instruments at one time right
so I know that doesn't sound like much
but that and then into the first four
track recorder like multitrack recording
like we didn't have any of that when we
were coming up you had to go into a
studio and it was the two inch 24 track
case and that was the only way you could
record you couldn't record anyway people
can record on their phones
now I've heard about these tapes yeah
okay so so since these years of tapes
and we've gotten more and more digital
and more and more high-tech in our films
I'm curious how you feel about tech
being like an integral part of the
filmmaking process and being used to
tell a story right so we get all the way
from fresh prints to men and black all
the way to Gemini met and we're like the
deck outside is necessary you have to
tell that story so if you could talk
about how you feel about tech being so
core to making that sort of thing happen
you know so when I started in in
entertainment the lack of tech was a
massive creative hindrance right it was
you could have an idea and it literally
could take you a month before you could
get the resources together to get the
idea out of your mind onto something you
could listen to right with music and
with film it was impossible if you had
if you had images in your mind you know
with a super8 camera to try to shoot
something and then try to sync it was
literally impossible so two things
happen with that so with what once with
rap music what happened was only the
best of the best got through right so
1986 the summer that me and Jeff
released our first album if I named all
the rappers you would know who they were
cause you it with your jazzy jeff and
fresh friends Heavy D eraklyon Rock
Public Enemy it's like you jet you
couldn't get through so then what
happens with technology as soon as
technology gets democratized and
everybody can do it and now more things
get out and there's a lesser quality to
the things that make it to to the world
so I would say technology is an absolute
necessity to advance human imagination
because really beautiful ideas die
inside of people and I remember
one time I heard Marvin Gaye say
something that was so cold he said he
was talking about a pain that he feels
and he said because there's he says I
have a song inside of me that I know is
great and I can't get it out so to me
that is a part of the human spirit that
technology is an enabler
it's an enabler yes to to be able to
allow us to explore ourselves and to as
angly said allow us to chase our
imagination even know and we'll never
catch it so now we get to know that was
deep you got a pause like when I say
something like that you I have like a
pause damn daddy can we get that on the
screen yeah you could put it on yeah
chase our imagination knowing that we'll
never catch it
so now Gemini man so I've seen that the
trailers in the plot of the movie is
insane so you're starring in the movie
yo and a younger version of yourself is
also starring at the same time on screen
absolutely I'll let that soak in first
yeah yeah you ready for that ready for
that that's kind of a lot so how does
this happen are you acting as one
character for a month and then switching
to the other are you going back and
forth what's really interesting so this
is the first 100% digital character you
know in the digital human yeah right
yeah well not digital carry yeah digital
human thank you for the correct no
problem but don't do that again
no it was the first I'm done that's all
I saw my Wikipedia page already see the
thing is I watched a Latin on the plane
it was like that's kind of a human but
also kind of a genius so we're all calls
the first hundred percent the first
hundred percent digital human right but
that's that that's interesting so
Aladdin was the same technology but
anytime you make someone blue and you
make them float and fly and all of that
there's a huge there's room to play with
it but
when you're trying to sell an emotional
scene that's a close-up and your on the
eyes and the eyes need to be wet and you
know you need to capture all of that in
a close-up that's the that's the leap
forward that Angley and weather are
attempting to make with with Gemini man
and I've described in the same way it's
not de-aging it's not my face and then
they you know flatten it out and make it
look younger no it's a 100% digital
creation based on my performance right
so in the same way in the Life of Pi
with the tiger right so they use the
tiger and they shot images of a tiger
and all that but in the movie creating
the movement of the tiger is 100%
digital they're not using the tiger as
an actor that's how it is with this
digital character to 100% digital human
would you say it's easier or more
difficult to work with so much tech and
because you're obviously acting with is
it a body double or no one is there or
how so it's it's a mixture sometimes
it's a another actor will be there to do
the the scene with me sometimes it's
nothing I'll just get an eyeline and
look and you you know depending on
what's best for the individual shot is
that that's a unique challenge I guess
yes absolutely and then it's a unique
challenge on the other side because
there's a whole head rig right that I
have to wear and it has cameras in front
right so if you and I are doing a scene
there's cameras that are right in front
so I can't really see into your eyes to
do the things you'd normally do to
capture a real acting performance right
interesting I'm gonna pivot to what I
think is fascinating which is your pivot
from being actor to also creator and
zone youtuber and all these other
different mediums how's that been like
that's been it's pretty new for you but
how do you think that's been going
somewhere I love it right so when you
make a movie
so the Gemini man yeah for when Gemini
man comes out it will have been over two
years right since only you know started
the process and over a year and a half
me being involved so two years for one
piece of content to go out is is
artistic death for me right you know
there's so many beautiful just tiny
thoughts and ideas that that can turn
into 60-second and four-minute content
and share to be able to to release
things into the world and I just felt
completely backed up and and you know
trapped with all of these creative ideas
and now with now started with YouTube
and and Instagram and just moving around
the different platforms and all the
different platforms speak to a different
type of creativity they all have a
different flow yeah yeah they they have
a different wavelength right you know
definitely because I see the Instagram
stuff versus like the vlogs like yeah
and I'm curious if it lets you I think
the obvious answer is yes but like
you're expressing your own ideas
absolutely more often than if you're
being directed yes absolutely and and
because it's it's not really directed
per se it's a you know it's you know
sort of half capturing real-life shoot
everything now so what I find is it
makes me explore and experience in ways
that I wouldn't have if I wasn't going
to shoot it you know we get into cities
you know we we get into you know Seoul
Korea and I'm exhausted but I know MLM a
is doing something so I wanna you know
when ago night actually makes me get out
of bed and go and explore and experience
him and meet people you know even this
time with you and doing this press
conference at the YouTube space it's
like it's an opportunity I wanted to
meet which I wanted to sit with you I
wanted to hear
what you think it's like it jogs that
creative beast in inside of me I love it
and then just as far as literal quality
we mentioned the red cameras yeah like
going from cuz you fancy
I mean you've met everyone has to shoot
with the regular the camera and your
smartphone today yes amazing video so if
I go back to like shooting fresh prints
or like me you know 20 years ago fun
fact by the way you've been shooting the
video longer than I've been alive
exactly what I was about to let me go
back that far obviously quality has
snipped up in a major way are there
things we don't think about as a viewer
that that you have to think about now
that the quality is better yes like
makeup is probably one of them yeah
exactly
yeah you know and it's funny you were
just saying that like there were no cell
phones when I got started like zero
right so when I was a teenager when the
first cell phone yeah came out but
nobody had them like you know rich
people had and they were two big bricks
and Japan was really the first country
that I saw full cell phone coverage like
the the the kids in Japan had cell
phones before before everybody so it was
a whole different way of interacting
human beings started to interact
differently when the the technology
expanded in that way I think it's
pushing people to be more honest you
know I think that just there's good and
bad with any tool but I think that
technology and what is being created and
how people are embracing it is going to
force humans to evolve I love that all
right so I have one more little series
of things to grab this so it let's do a
little little meme review meme review
you've got a couple
Wolf's nail Oh related quick okay ameen
ameen review and I want you to I'm gonna
show them to you and and people see them
too but also if you could shed some
light on either the behind the scenes or
you remember what's being shot am I
gonna be embarrassed at all cuz I want
to prepare myself if I'm gonna be in
bear let's go with no and I want to have
I want to have my team grab stuff of you
in case you're embarrassing yeah this
will be fun
yes this was this was a time in my life
when I was as wild and free as I had
ever been I would say anything in front
of a camera I would do anything and
there was a raw recklessness to my
creativity that I'm actually seeking
right now like I want to make my way
back to that say anything do anything
space like this guy well he was a wild
boy you got a message alright next name
you don't don't want to know who's
cinnamon is you know that's the that is
the same period okay if I can recall
like during during this time I started
expanding my performances because Martin
had just come on okay right the air and
I remember watching Martin's show and
when I watched Martin know they liked
the wildness of his comedy I was like I
got to turn it up I got to turn it up a
notch so this was this was definitely in
my keep up with Martin stage okay now
this is I think a talk show oh yeah
I don't know what the hell I was doing
an hour that's just a great emotions
Ostrom together
yeah that is crazy okay that was
embarrassing that was the other tools go
that was the Lord oh what's weird about
this one is the context people use it
for its visually really lightweight but
this is like yeah this is the final
episode of fresh prints it's funny I
learned a really valuable lesson in this
right because the the the network wanted
to do one more season of The Fresh
Prince and I remember I was considering
I was going to do one more season of The
Fresh Prince and we had we've done an
episode of something with John Amos and
John Amos came to me said hey man listen
he said don't overstay your welcome on
on TV he was like you're doing great
stuff he's like you do not want to get
cancelled in the middle of a season it's
like go out on your terms the way that
you want to go out be able to say
goodbye to your fans don't get caught
okay it bends in so this was the sixth
season and I had an opportunity to do
one more season but I was feeling like
the quality wasn't necessarily going to
stay up and I decided to end the show in
the sixth season and do you think that's
like some of the better advice you've
gotten it oh my goodness it's I the the
being prepared for the next thing is so
wildly critical I think life in general
is rise and fall everything is rise and
fall and there's been a couple times in
my life where I got caught holding on to
the last wave while it's the while it's
dying oh I have a good quote for that
yeah I have a KC nice that quote where
cases like that tart I don't even he
probably did make this up but Tarzan
can't get to the next branch of yes
absolutely yeah absolutely and you've
got to be when you
you're grabbing that first one and
you're holding it it's going to be there
it's fantastic but you gotta know that
you're gonna have to let go at some
point because the same thing that saved
your life if you hang on it'll kill you
got it that's deep
like you did take a pause let's go on
one more me good times yeah - I got
smashed for this although you know and I
brought you down with me or this would
I'd say it was a height yeah yeah I
brought you down is that I won't do this
neck necks I'm really I'm really elevate
well that's a lot I'm gonna marry love
with your door thank you so much